الشارع الفرنسي والسلطات كذلك على موعد
غدا مع موجه عاشره من الاحتجاجات المندده
بقانون التقاعد الجديد شلل تام بقطاع
النقل ومظاهرات واشتباكات تحولت اختبارا
للرئيس الفرنسي لطريقه تعامله طبعا مع
الازمه فالموجات المتسعه
التظاهرات السابقه
بنيت وتحول منها الغضب الفرنسي من قانون
التقاعد نحو ماكرون نفسه فاقرار القانون
وقانون التقاعد برفع سن التقاعد الى 64
عاما دون تصويت برلماني كامل جعل ماكنو
يقترب شيئا فشيئا من ازمه دستوريه بعيده
طبعا عن ازمه اجتماعيه موجوده اصلا طبيعه
الاحتجاجات الضخمه تغيرت خلال الاسبوع
الماضي واتسمت بغضب كبير وعنف اكبر احيانا
اما في الحسابات السياسيه فتصريحات ماكرون
التي استفزت الشارع الفرنسي
بشعبيته للتراجع الى مستويات غير مسبوقه
امام حزب التجمع الوطني الذي تتزعمه كما
هو معلوم مارين لوبان فزعيمه اقصى اليمين
المستفيد الاكبر من السخطه الشعبيه الواسع
على ماكرون بحسب صحيفه
الفرنسيه لبى ارتفع داعمي مرشحي حزب لوبان
بخمس نقاط مقارنه طبعا باستطلاع سابق جرى
في نوفمبر الماضي ورغم ان الاحتجاجات
تركزت حول سن التقاعد الا ان فئه من
الشباب كانت من الاكثر مشاركه وحماسه في
هذه المظاهرات طبعا السبب الاساسي هو
القلق على مستقبل وعدم رضا على رئيس قالوا
انه لا يصلح الا للاغنيه
[موسيقى]